[Music]
the European Commission is putting 560
million euros on the table with 36
concrete actions for our ocean
this action span from global cooperation
with our partners to small gestures in
our everyday life
we cannot underestimate the effect that
our daily actions have on our
environment and how human actions can
slowly destroy our natural surroundings
even something as vast as the ocean this
small beautiful blue dot of a planet may
have been miss named it is not earth it
is actually mostly sea and we are
utterly reliant upon it nothing is more
contagious than example I'm convinced
that again today you will have
contaminated all of us with much
goodwill to move forward what are we
thinking that we now enter the 21st
century with so little access only 10%
of the ocean has been seen let alone
explored by humankind and yet we behave
as if we have the answers raise your
right hand and admit it come on I suck
and I hear before everybody pledged to
stop sucking future generations are
going to look back at this era as the
time where we reset our relationship
with the ocean the task of conserving
the oceans is not only a matter of
States but of every one of every person
I have the greatest honor and privilege
to and
behalf of the newer government to fear
new wave and the people of new wave our
intentions to commit 40% of our
exclusive economic zone to be declared
as a large-scale marine protected area
it's time for all of us now to give the
ocean a right to be protected to be
sufficiently able to protect themselves
my vision is to have a Paris agreement
for the ocean the science and data tells
us we have to act but it is our humanity
that compels us to when we came out of
the Stone Age we didn't leave the Stone
Age behind because we ran out of stones
we left it because we found something
better after 200 years of the Industrial
Revolution this is a time to find
something better and to move on to a
blue economy it's not a question of
whether we can do it this is a question
of the political will to do it
my friends we need to guarantee that we
are making this a political movement we
need to make sure we have this movement
reaching out to people all across
country every country it is only when
you and I and all mankind commits to
stand up for speak for and care for the
ocean can we have the audacity to call
it our ocean throughout the ages we've
been having discussions in human
communities about whether sea monsters
actually exist today we know they do and
it's called marine litter and ocean
plastics you can count on the European
Union to lead the way both at home and a
partnership with you abroad and you can
count on 500 million Europeans to act as
champions of sustainability this is the
future to whom you have given a little
bit more
of hope this is not our ocean I agree
with Silvia this is their ocean and it
is our responsibility to give it back to
them safe healthy and sustainable
[Music]